Well, localization is a remarkable phenomenon,
in which the propagation of waves can be confined
in a very small portion of their original
domain although nothing visibly prevents it.
One can imagine, for example, a drum in which
vibrations stay in a tiny portion of the membrane
— for no apparent reason.
But one talks about the localization of waves
more generally.
One shouldn't imagine purely mechanical vibrations.
Light is waves, and sound propagation is waves.
And, from the point of view of quantum physics,
even matter is waves.
Localization can be caused by irregularities
of the boundaries, by impurities of the material,
or by some sort of disorder.
And then particularly, a very well known example
of localization is Anderson localization by
disorder for quantum states of electrons.
The problem with localization is that there
is a great variety of waves, and there is
an infinite number of even simplest blocks
of waves which we call eigenfunctions.
So it is very difficult to understand and
describe all of them at the same time.
The landscape function is sort of a magic
information box — a solution to one simple
mathematical equation — which tells us where
eigenfunctions are localized, where the waves
are localized, what are their shapes and it
even tells us what are the energies at which
localization occurs.